[music]
>> This audio media can be utilized in
various different ways. On individual
level
if you want to hear the audio in your
home or in your office, you have a
desktop model. We had the audio cassette
players, now MP3 players. We don't have
audio cassette players now. We have some
DVD players in your home in your office
or maybe you're in a traveling
in a bus, in a train, in a plane.
No recorders, only put the plug direct
from the server it comes and you can
listen.
Now you're going in the plane, 500
channels, 1,000 channels.
Emirates was one of the first.
Previously, we used to have channels
only in the business class and first
class.
In economy, no, only five channels,
that's it.
Now in economy, we have 500 channels.
Emirates was the first. And now I'm told
1,000 channels, out of which half audio,
half video.
Traveling.
You can utilize it on a group level when
you're going for a function
a party, wedding party, birthday party.
Not that you have to do birthday party,
I'm not telling you. How to do Dawah.
You can do Dawah in things which you
disagree also.
You can go to a party which is not
correct and yet do Dawah if you have the
guts to do Dawah.
So you have a gathering, a family
gathering, you can utilize it. And
utilize a larger system. And when you're
in the public level
in public level, you're using the public
address system.
Which again, we will be dealing even
with audio
in this training program to a certain
level. Not in detail, but one session on
public address system. And we'll be
having a specialist coming
something like voice culture.
Who knows what is voice culture?
We had culture wearing clothes.
We had culture in medicine, you know, we
have culture of media, etc. Voice
culture means how you train your voice.
And you might have seen, you're watching
Peace TV, the solution for humanity. You
heard that?
Have you heard that before?
Peace TV, the solution for humanity.
That wasn't me. I'm not expert on voice
culture.
I'm not expert on background of voice.
He'll be having a person here,
inshallah. I've requested him, he's a
very famous personality from India by
the name of Harish Bhimani.
He's a non-Muslim.
And he appears to be a fan of me. Though
I have not met him anytime personally,
I've spoken to him on phone. He was one
of the top
in India.
Every sentence he speaks
he judges
10,000 rupees. At that time it was $200
every sentence.
So he was going to speak for 45 minutes,
but it's going to be free, inshallah.
Well, if he's charging me per sentence
and he speaks about 2,000 or 3,000
sentences, multiply by $200, khalas.
We'll be there one of the days,
inshallah. But this is public speaking.
That is, he is a specialist in
background
voice.
I'm not a specialist in background.
He may not be able to do what I can do.
And I cannot do what he can do. I can
imitate it. You're watching Peace TV,
the solution for humanity.
10%. Otherwise, I would have been there.
I'm not a I'm a die.
But that's an art.
It's a different ballgame altogether,
which will have a little bit of audio.
In public meeting of a public address
system, we'll deal, inshallah, one day
on public address system. It's a
separate specialty of public address
system. That's audio media. Then
we also have on a higher level radio
broadcast stations.
That's on a
big level. Not a public level, public at
large.
Talking about hundreds of thousands and
millions of people.
That we will not be covering in this
session because time is limited. If we
had the time, if we had 50 days, we
would have done it.
This is the second type of media called
as audio.
Each media has its advantage,
disadvantage. Audio media has its own
advantage, print media has its own
advantage. The third is the video media.
Video media is what you store today on
HD DVD.
The VCD is gone, DVD is gone. Now HD DVD
is high definition DVD. DVD is digital
video disc, short form. We use the word
DVD, but we don't know what is DVD. It
is digital video disc.
CD-ROM is compact disc.
ROM. CD-ROM. What is ROM?
What's the full form of ROM?
Read-only memory.
CD-ROM. We say CD-ROM, but we
So video, we can store what we see
normally on the lower level is
HD DVD, Blu-ray. On a higher level,
we're talking about high definition
tape, we're talking about LTO-6. We'll
discuss that, inshallah, on Dawah
through satellite in detail. Same thing,
this can be on individual level, you can
see on your own screen.
Whether you were at home or whether
you're traveling in a bus or whether in
a train or a plane, you have a screen in
front of you. First you had small
screen, now when you go to business
class, 20 in. First class with 24 in.
Full lying flat, all at your fingertips.
1,000 channels, what do you want?
Most of them haram, that's different.
Few airlines show halal.
Saudi Airlines and they show even videos
of Dawah, alhamdulillah, including
myself. Now we have offer from Qatar TV.
And will you give your DVD? I said I've
got no copyright, no problem. Good.
So even Dawah can be done in the plane.
Who would imagine person paying money
and you're doing Dawah to him? Good.
Times are changing.
But that's a different technique. We
will deal part of it. The third level is
on a group level, you're having a
function, you're showing a
video recording of a die, you're showing
a documentary, you're showing a movie,
or whatever it is, on Islam following
the rules of Quran and Sunnah.
On a big level, it is a satellite.
Which we'll discuss on satellite,
inshallah, I think on the seventh day.
Dawah through satellite, which wasn't
done in the previous training programs.
Dawah through video has its own pros and
cons.
Benefits.
Specialty.
A person who is a specialist on audio
doesn't have to be a specialist
in video. Yes, there are some people who
Allah has blessed and they become
specialists in many fields,
alhamdulillah. So pray to Allah to make
you that person who is specialist in
variety.
But you can only do that when you behave
like zero and then become a hero.
Whenever you meet a specialist, you know
he's a specialist.
Like Harish Bhimani comes, oh, now he's
not a Muslim.
You want to do Dawah with him, do. Fine.
But gain
what you can gain
from him. That's an art.
Next is Dawah through electronic media.
And by electronic media, I mean the
internet.
Previously, we had
the emails, then we had the web pages,
then we had the bulletin, we had the
blog. And all this is getting a little
bit obsolete.
Some things are yet there, website is
yet there. I remember when we started in
we were one of the first Islamic
organizations that made website and we
were very happy and I spent months on
it.
And now I don't look at it.
Now people say there's a mistake, I said
I don't have time because we have gone
high. When you do wholesale, you forget
the retail.
We have gone on a higher level, so I
said, okay, let my assistant, let my
junior junior handle it.
At that time, it was our main
core. I remember books were initially
our main
The print, okay. Some books we are
printing at a low quality, some books
very clear, some books a little bit not
very clear. So we used to even sort out.
I used to be the person sorting out
which book to give where.
Because that was my best activity. I
used to give my time. I give my maximum
time in the best activity I'm doing in
which I'm getting the best Dawah.
So at one time, my best work
distributing books. Now we don't think,
we have got containers. When people say
we want to give you books to distribute,
we say jazakallah, we don't have the
time.
There are people sending us containers.
We say sorry, that's not our specialty.
It's good. Okay, give it to that
organization.
XYZ. That organization cannot clear the
books for me. Then we come to the
picture, okay, take money, we clear it.
And then we are stuck with it and then
we
Because they've reached a level now.
When you are doing wholesale, don't try
and do wholesale and retail together.
When you try and grab too much, then you
left. Wholesale is wholesaler.
So when we are talking about reaching
millions, we forget about yet we have
print media, yet has its pros and cons,
both. So as for satellite media, we'll
discuss, inshallah, more in detail,
again
on a larger level
on the seventh day. We were discussing
electronic media. Electronic media, many
of the old things have become obsolete.
And now we also have social media, which
wasn't there when internet started. We
have the social media.
We have the Twitter.
We have the Facebook. We have the
Instagram.
We have the YouTube.
Now each thing has a different
technology, different expertise. Social
media by itself has an expertise. What
you do on the Facebook is different what
you do on the Twitter.
Alhamdulillah, we are there on the
Facebook. We'll deal with that
on the day of Dawah through social
media.
How to do that, inshallah. Everything
specialty. So we have chosen a few of
the specialty, we started it unique
We became specialist alhamdulillah
reached
high levels. We'll discuss that more
on the day of Dawah to social media. So,
electronic media has advanced to great
level. At present, according to me, the
most the biggest reach so far is the
satellite media.
Each media has its advantage and
disadvantage. Print media is depleting,
becoming less and less, yet it will
never become obsolete.
The usage will become less and less and
less, never obsolete because print media
hard copy has its own advantage. What do
you have a hard copy in your library is
different than what you have a soft
copy. That is the reason there are
libraries. For example, you go to Dubai,
there is a library of Jamal Masjid. He
takes microfilms of all these authentic
Quran if you have.
The original copy has a different value
in the Topkapi Museum, costing millions
of dollars, right? It has its value.
So, print media will never become
obsolete. It will become less and less
important.
Now, you have email, you have news on
your mobile. You go anywhere, in the
washroom also you are listening and you
are hearing on your mobile, on your this
message SMS. But, newspaper will never
become obsolete.
It will become less and yet today
two things on which maximum money is
spent is on television media and
newspaper.
Yet,
it may become obsolete.
It will not become zero.
Newspaper may become obsolete. Now, what
you can do with a newspaper you cannot
do with other media.
Yes, people are changing. So, print
media has its own specialty.
What I'm telling you now on the stage
has nothing to do with print media.
Matter can be used everywhere. Now, when
you hear a matter,
we'll come to know the percentage later
on. You can use it anywhere.
But, technique of public speaking is
different, technique of print media is
different. What I'll be starting from
tomorrow that you cannot apply. Print
media has a different technique. How do
you start? What do you do? What language
you use, etc.
It has its own advantage and
disadvantage.
Audio media has its own advantage and
disadvantage. Video media has its own
advantage and disadvantage. Satellite
media has its own and even the
electronic media. Paper you can carry
anywhere in your pocket.
Fine? And you can read it whenever you
want. Previously, we could not see a
television anywhere. Now, we can. You
take out a mobile, yeah, you can see.
So, mobility was there in the print
media, wasn't there in the other media.
But, now as technology is improving,
this gap is reducing and the negative
factors are being deleted in the other
media and positive is added. Previously,
who could have heard? When the
television came, I remember in '70s when
we were kids, television means something
good. You all gather together to see a
television, big television.
When mobile came, so big the mobile was
and so expensive.
Now, all smartphone, but even the kid is
playing with it.
You want to hear some news online, you
can see it. Peace TV also is there on
mobile. One of the first Islamic
channels to come, but the reach is less,
different different process.
The first religious channel Islamic to
come on the mobile was Peace TV many
years back. So, one thing that print
media has got mobility,
but it is voluminous.
Now, all these what I showed you in my
mobile, I can have 100 times more.
What I showed you on the stage,
I can have 1,000 times more material on
my mobile.
It depends upon the
capacity.
My mobile has 128
GB.
iPhone 6.
It can have all the translations, all
the Hadiths, everything.
Mobility.
Yes, if it's not available, then I may
open for Quran. Anyone ask Quran
reference, okay, then I may open up.
Otherwise, at home, I would prefer
reading from my book, better
concentration, everything. So, it has
its advantages, disadvantages. The
reason why it is being depleted in the
media of audio and in the print. You had
Walkman earlier.
You have got the Discman where you can
move and watch.
In the social media, social media has
its limitation. You used to use a big
computer with a CPU. Social media means
you had to go to a cyber cafe. Now,
where is the cyber cafe? Hardly you
find. Cyber cafe means you have to go to
a special cafe where big machines are
kept. Now, everything is in your pocket.
What cyber cafe you want? The full cyber
cafe is in your pocket.
Technology is changing. The negative
factors are being reduced.
But, you should be updated with the
technology. As a Dawah,
if you are a good doctor, you have to
read the latest journals.
What are the latest things in medicine,
which I'm not doing. I'm doing what's
required for Dawah, yes.
I'm not doctor of body, I'm doctor of
soul, alhamdulillah.
So, you have to be in touch with all
these things.
Inshallah, we'll discuss more in details
on the seventh day Dawah to satellite
and after a few days Dawah to social
media, inshallah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.